it takes a particular type of person to
survive a probable state sanction
poisoning and then return to the country
you believe tried to kill you
a country where you face imminent arrest
but alexei navalny never gave the
slightest suggestion
he would do anything else following
months of recuperation in germany
alexei and wife yulia took their seats
on a moscow-bound plane from berlin
boy bring us a little vodka we're flying
home says julia
quoting a much loved russian gangster
movie it's a nevali hallmark
that he and his family make light of the
many dangers they face
and what he faced was jail on arrival
he'd violated his suspended sentence
by leaving russia to receive life-saving
treatment
he makes a choice as a brave man because
he always pretended
he is a brave man who
has no fear before the authorities
he has no fear of putin he has no fear
of
law and order machine now it's the time
to prove uh
prove these claims
and show the deeds that's why
if he states abroad
well he diminishes his claims of being
well number one
and brave opposition at the airport
where he was due to land
police detained members of his team and
threw supporters out
navalny's plane was then diverted to
another moscow airport
away from the crowds after landing he
spoke to the journalists who traveled
with him
i am not afraid i feel okay walking
through immigration i will pass it and
go home because i know that i am right
i know that all the criminal cases
against me have been forged
all these scary stories that they have
tried to scare me with it is not only
the truth by my side but also the courts
but at passport control after a goodbye
kiss with his wife
police led navalny away the kremlin
denies the fsb had any role in last
year's novichok poisoning that nearly
kills the opposition leader
but now it seems likely russia will jail
nobony
for surviving it rory challenge to zero